because there's a lot of political
awareness around it this is also the
time to fix the tax system and the CCC
TV is a way to fix the tax systems the
CCC TV makes it impossible for a
multinational corporation to take its
profit from one GU member state and hide
it in a tax haven in inside the European
Union we all stand to benefit from this
proposal as European citizens common
consultative corporate tax base would
benefit SMEs and with that also a
European economy greatly with putting
less resources into legislation we would
have also more resources to invest any
tax incentives and investing too hard II
definitely make us invest more and would
make us more innovative
we have profits in Germany and we have
losses in another European state and now
we cannot put them together there as the
triple CTB of course would help by the
cross-border set-off of losses with the
triple CTB approach the one-stop shop
question which is very important for us
and also for other victorian enterprises
will be solved because it means that an
enterprises to give only one text income
statement in one country and the text
administration will then discuss the
further on go infestations with the
other text administration's in Europe
and that's how it should be the
implementation of this proposal will
lead to tech certainty tech certainty is
extremely important it's important for
business for the taxpayers because they
have to know the rules which are
relevant for them but tech certainty is
also important for the governments
because they need stable or revenues
this is good for everybody this is good
for the governments for the European
citizens it could make things easier for
us it is an interest of the European
business yes this is a big step forward